you saw that flooded Burning Man what's
the cause of the flooding according to
the view Donald Trump this is one of the
many tragedies this this summer uh due
to climate change has been one number
one existential problem it rained three
months worth over 24 hours but when I
hear Republicans say oh it's not
man-made it's not about fossil fuels you
know when Trump was President all of
that went up the fossil fuel usage went
up and the regulations to the planet
please don't vote for him I'm begging
you get him out of here he's so
dangerous droughts
climate change floods
climate change fire
that's climate change freeze it's
climate change you stubbed your toe this
morning getting out of bed that's
climate change I would never attribute
the power of the weather to Donald Trump